shortly taxpayers strongly oppose  forking over money for a new sports  stadium and they want to break up the  school district our eight news now  emerson college the hill poll showing by  three to one voters want to break up the  clark county school district many state  leaders have announced their support for  that but 40 percent were still unsure  and polls show just 17 percent favored a  deal like the 750 million dollars in  room tax money that we gave to the  raiders politicians like governor steve  sisilak and joe lombardo have also said  they opposed a similar deal for the  oakland nays  regarding like a new sports stadium it  looks like  the football stadium was the last one  that the the voters want to support  even if regardless of the success of it  doesn't look like nearly three to one  they don't want to put any more taxpayer  money into another arena